il ya quelques instants à peine neuf
restaurants moscovites ont reçu leur
toute première étoile michelin avec
l'arrivée tant attendue du prestigieux
guide gastronomique dans la capitale
russe la russie devient ainsi la trente
cinquième destination au monde à
accueillir le guide rouge selon des
critères tels que la qualité des
ingrédients et la créativité du chef
l'équipe du michelin décerne une deux ou
trois étoiles aux meilleurs
établissements visités par ces
inspecteurs anonymes à ce soir le guide
michelin sélectionné 60 9 restaurants
sur moscou donc sélect restaurant une
étoile et deux restaurants avec deux
étoiles et on considère c'est
probablement seulement le début parce
que la scène culinaire de moscou est
vraiment très prometteuse avec des
produits exceptionnels un carrefour
d'influencés extraordinaire et puis à
une génération de chefs de talent
extrêmement créatif qui sont aussi un
très influent et nous avons nous
regardons vraiment le futur de la
gastronomie en russie et en particulier
à moscou avec un très grand optimisme
pour le maire de moscou cette remise des
toilettes un soutien moral au secteur de
la restauration
durement touché par la pandémie de
coronavirus les chefs et les
restaurateurs se réjouissent de aussi de
cette marque de reconnaissance
internationale et seront beaucoup
d'efforts depuis des années déjà aussi
bien dans les productions alimentaires
dans la recherche de produits que les
chefs dans leur travail quotidien et à
tout le monde mais venaient à moscou
voir ce qui se fait venez voir les
restaurants et personne n'est venu de
france pour ainsi dire pour voir ce
qu'il fait à moscou et à moscou ya
vraiment des choses intéressantes pas
seulement moscou saint pétersbourg aussi
et les petits gars qui vont bien
en fait je suis très heureux et fier une
organisation étrangère sérieuse qui
distingue de bons restaurants soit venu
en russie
jamais autant de restaurateurs et de
cuisinier n'avait été réunis dans la
même salle je n'ai jamais rien vu de
pareil
iago match et je suis fier qu'en
occident on est remarqué les cuisiniers
les restaurateurs russe c'est formidable
je crois
cela stimulera la restauration russes
les exploitations agricoles les
compétences culinaires les serveurs le
design j'estime que c'est vraiment très
positif
au virus dans toute sa diversité
subtilité est ainsi mis à l'honneur il
ne fait aucun doute
11h52
ne jouera que stimuler la caisse qui
gagne
à tanger
et des classiques
[Musique]